vous êtes plutôt théâtre au cinéma +
cinéma franchement ça avec les potes les
six débats ça y va mais le théâtre avec
les petites chéries théâtre de corps on
y va de temps en temps là où ça bouge
en attendant l'éclaircie oui en
attendant l'éclaircie voilà vous dégagez
non mais bien ou pas non ça c'est un
temps par les eaux était retrouvée c'est
ce qu'on vous dit en attendant
l'éclaircie à la cité théâtre rue de
bretagne avoue sabine
c'est pas vraiment le soleil à camjac
aujourd'hui c'est pas grave
l'éclaircie est à l'intérieur bonjour
radio 1 bonjour ça va
alors ça y est c'est parti b oui c'est
parti septième année quatrième édition
partie ce soir ce qu'est ce qu'on voit
alors cette étoile david jean pierre à
19 heures avec un seul en scène ensuite
c'est enchaîne avec la femme silva
excusez moi et il faut que tu aies voir
david elle avait il a un petit souci est
de 190 bonsoir bonsoir livier alors donc
on disait david jean pierre 19 heures et
après à 21h la femme cible et puis aussi
orange diatonique
4e édition ça veut dire j'ai vu il ya de
la danse du théâtre de la chanson
partout ici c'est tout à fait naturel
la vie sous terre est surpuissant on
voit en effet différente sans de théâtre
différents types de musique attend
téléphone l'idée c'est toujours ça c'est
d'ouvrir les portes d'un vrai théâtre
c'est nourrir les trous oui d'accueillir
d'accueillir des côtes des jeunes
compagnies dans des conditions
professionnelles de travail de montrer
leur travail de rencontrer du public de
faire de la place j'ai envie de faire de
la place aux compagnies émergentes aux
jeunes aux femmes aussi c'est qu'on
travaille aussi beaucoup sur le pardon
si tu peux pousser on repasse aussi
beaucoup de travail sur la parité hommes
femmes égalité hommes femmes c'est
important
alors en attendant l'éclaircie c'est du
8 au 12 février vous trouvez tout le
programme sur le net 1 en attendant
l'éclaircie point fr merci coût 2 merci
au raja garde merci là où ça bouge on
avait parlé ici pour vous annoncer la
sortie un bal tout neuf celui de
mandarine pour les enfants et demain au
zénith de caen à partir de 14h30 venez
danser et retrouver l'emploi soir sous
de la guitare rien qu'à part il joue de
la guitare d'abord jan gassmann
à sac est capable